let's review a little bit what we've
learned about reserve banking and then
we'll extend this to the notion of an
elastic money supplier a money supply
that can grow or contract as people need
money or hopefully grows and contracts
as people need money so let me create a
couple of normal commercial banks maybe
i'll call these national banks they have
a national charter so let's say i have
some
equity
and part of that equity
most of it is some
gold that i initially capitalized the
bank with and then some of it is a
building i'm trying to draw this as neat
as possible but
you understand my situation then i take
some
gold deposits from whoever the farmers
after the crop has been
harvested
and then off setting that i have all of
the farmers deposits
i'll do that in a blue color
so that's one farmer's deposit
that's another farm maybe there's only
two farmers
and then we learned in fractional
reserve banking uh that
that i can leverage up this amount of
capital i had and there's a certain
ratio between the amount of capital in
this case gold or reserves i have and
the amount of demand deposits i can have
so let's say my reserve requirement in
this world is
just because i don't want this bank to
become too tall let's say it's 50 we
know in reality reserve requirements are
more like
10
but let me write that down reserve
requirement is 50
so that means that my ratio of
gold to demand deposit accounts cannot
be any less than 50 so whatever this
amount is i can double it in terms of
demand deposit accounts and the way i do
that say see this amount
let's say this is collectively
100
so i could have up to 100 let's say this
is right here this is 50.
so i could have up to 200 in demand
deposit account so i can essentially
lend out money and create demand deposit
accounts
this is all review for you hopefully so
i could lend out
150
let me draw that i could lend out 150
i want to make this neat looking
those are my liabilities and then these
are my loans and my
so that's one loan i make out and i just
create someone's checking account that's
the loan asset and i create a demand
deposit account for them that's the
liability this here could be a big loan
etc and then i'm not the only bank in
this universe so let me
let me copy and paste this control c
control v there my other bank the
universe i just want to show you that
there are multiple banks
then we said there are a couple of
issues with this
you know you have a 50 reserve
requirement which is very high but what
if there is a situation where for
whatever reason your reserves
temporarily drop below that 50 percent
how do you get that extra gold you don't
want to go to people and say hey can i
have a little bit more gold then they're
going to get scared and i'll pull out of
your system but if you're a little bit
below 50 but if the other bank is a
little bit above 50 it would be it'd be
a convenient way if you could borrow
from that other bank or even better if
there was a central depository where all
of these gold reserves were then you
could just depos you could borrow
directly from that central depository if
there were no other bank to borrow from
so you could kind of view it as a lender
of last resort and we'll go into more of
the technicalities of that when we in
particular talk about our current system
with that said we created a reserve bank
where we put these
where we put these deposits
so let's see there's 200 of deposits in
this world let me see if i can just copy
and paste that
whoops
let me see if i can just copy and paste
that
so that's one of the reserves
and then they're the same so then that's
the other reserve
it doesn't look that neat
and all the banks got together and
created this it's a private bank but
we'll go into more details of of how the
actual federal reserve works so those
are the actual gold reserves
those are the assets of that bank
actually i should
move it over
some
that creates a because that's an asset
of this new bank and let me fill that
part in with black
okay and then the liabilities for this
central reserve bank
let me draw the liabilities
i'll draw them in red
the liabilities these are the demand
deposit accounts
for these
nationally chartered banks
so
this he took all of his gold put it here
and so now he
has let me
to simplify he he has a demand deposit
account but i'll assume that he just got
federal not he got reserved notes to
show that he had access to this gold so
let's say that
this is um
let me draw it right
so this is a hundred
notes outstanding
this part corresponding to 100 gold
pieces and this is another hundred
although notes outstanding it's fungible
you could mix them up because you don't
know where they came from or whatever
that's what's different about those
relative to a checking account 100 notes
outstanding and so essentially this guy
gives his gold here and in exchange he
gets these federal reserve notes which
look
like green pieces of paper
and now these are actually his reserves
his reserves are no longer gold his
reserves are how much of these federal
reserve notes he has
and we learned in the last video that
only the federal reserve or the reserve
bank i haven't called it the federal
reserve yet but i think you see where
this is going
only they can issue these notes and
these notes
are these rectangular green pieces of
paper with
with faces of presidents on them
et cetera
et cetera and let's say the in the
government we live in
they kind of sanction even though this
is a officially a private bank this this
reserve bank
it's set up in such a way that even
though these all of the original banks
might have originally capitalized it
with some equity that they really don't
get any of the profits of this bank and
i'll go into detail on how the actual
federal reserve works but let's just say
any surplus profits of this bank
actually just go
back to the federal government so the
federal government doesn't these banks
don't make any money off of this and
actually let's say that the board of
directors of this bank is actually
appointed by the government et cetera et
cetera so
it's key to the financial system so what
the government says you know these notes
sure it's issued it's issued by this
reserve bank but we want people to have
a lot of faith in this currency because
this is the currency that we use in our
world in our nation so in order for
people have unlimited faith in this
currency
we are we are going to make an
obligation of the government
so it's issued by the bank let me write
that down this used to confuse me to no
end
issued by the bank
issued by the reserve bank
but it's an obligation
obligation
of the government of the government now
what does that mean well that means that
if for whatever reason even if
this reserve bank were to somehow not
have the gold to back it up
it would go bankrupt but even in that
situation the government
would still be obligated to give you the
gold equivalent of these notes whatever
we decided is maybe it's you know 35 of
these dollars per ounce of gold or
whatever but that's what that means so
that gives a lot of people confidence
that that these things are you can
almost say as good as gold and and why
do you why does it matter that the
government how do you how can you trust
the government well the government can
just tax people whether they're going to
tax them in terms of dollars whether
they can tax them in terms of gold
whether they can tax them in terms of
goods and services so as long as you
think that that economy whatever the
this economy is that this government is
governing over as long as you think that
that economy can somehow support the
gold
to back this up you should say oh this
is this is as good as gold or at least
support the goods and services
well that that said let's introduce the
notion of an e-last
elastic currency actually before i do
that let's go back to one one thing this
government does so we said it's an
obligation of the government
right which means if all else fails the
government is going to give you the
value behind these notes i want to
introduce you to another concept which
is actually very similar to these notes
and that is a a government debt or
government borrowing so let me let me
draw that down here i think i'm going to
run out of time but i'll continue it in
the next video so i'm the government
right so i mean you could almost view
the government's asset as
its its ability to tax people but
if if i'm the government and i issue
these government ious
government iou and we'll call them
treasury bonds and bills
government
ious
let's call them treasuries generally
treasury bills are short-term treasuries
where the government bars for a shorter
amount of time bonds are longer term i
think i've gone over that in the yield
curve video but i'll do that in more
detail but they're just ious from the
government
now
these are going to be considered as
risk-free why are they considered
risk-free because they are denominated
in the same currency that the government
that the economy that this government
governs over operates in so if if this
government and i think you can
understand that this is essentially the
u.s government if it borrows money from
you so
it gives you an iou so this is me let's
say this is me this is the government
if it gives me this iou and i give it
a hundred dollars
if i give it a hundred dollars and
that's these things
why do i know that this iou is risk-free
well because unless he starts the
government i i'm making him masculine
but unless they start issuing an
unusual number of ious and just have so
much interest that they can't sustain
you know that they can always tax more
people to get you back
your hundred dollar bills so you view
this thing right here
as risk risk-free so whenever the
government goes out there and says hey
everyone we have a new war we want to
fight or some new type of uh scheme new
bureaucracy we would like to create we
are going to borrow money from you
someone is going to someone is going to
give them their
currency their federal reserve notes and
in exchange the government's going to
give them these risk-free ious and then
the government can use these reserve
notes to go buy goods and services or
pay soldiers or pay the bureaucrats
now we're going to use that idea in the
next video to learn how
this federal reserve bank or this
reserve bank can buy and sell
these government securities in order to
change the money supply see you in the
next video